اود منك
تعليقا عما شاهدته من الصور التي حصلت
عليها الجزيره لاستدراج كتائب القسام جنود
الاحتلال الى فتحه نفق هذه الطريقه وهذه
الاليه وتلك السيطره في
اثناء
الاستدراج حسن دعنا نضع اذا صح التعبير
الانفاق في الاطار التكتيكي والعملانية
الخطوط الداخليه وهي الاسهل والاه بالنسبه
لها اذا تقدم الجيش الاسرائيلي تستشر
المقاومه وتنزل الخسائر واذا تراجع كما
حصل في غزه مدينه غزه ايضا يصبح حريه اكثر
للمقاومه للقيام بعمليات الاغاره والكمائن
ولكن ما هو الجديد الذي استجد في معركه
غزه حسن شيء مهم جدا ان بين الخطوط
الخارجيه والخطوط حيث تقط المقاومه
المقاومه قادره على تجاوز الخطوط الداخليه
والخارجيه عبر الانفاق وحتى ضرب الخطوط
الخارجيه من وراء الخطوط يعني هي قادره
على ضرب كل الخطوط الاساسيه واللوجستيه
لجيش الاسرائيلي او جيش الاحتلال في
خلفيته هذا شيء جديد لم يعتده يعني اليوم
ان تستجر ان تستدرج
المقاومه نعم تفضل ان تستدرج
المقاومه
ان تستدرج
المقاومه جيش الاحتلال الى نفق هو من ضمن
مساحه معينه ومركز قتال او ساحه قتال
معينه والهاجس دائما اليوم ان كان في
الشمال او الوسط او الجنوب هو هذه الانفاق
وهو شكل وحده عسكريه خاصه او ما يسمى
بالتاسار يعني هي مهمتها بالاضافه الى
الهندسه بالاضافه الى الخصائص والاختصاص
ان تبحث عن ه هذه الانفاق وهي استدرجته
كما استدرجت جيش الاحتلال في عده مناسبات
اذا كان الهاجس دائما ان يكون النفق
فلنعرف و نقوم بتفخيخ تماما هذه النقطه
اود
ان ان اعلق عليها واسالك بشانها قوات
الاحتلال تضع الانفاق كهدف رئيسي ل في
عملياتها العسكريه لكن عندما
تتكرر عمليات الاست ادراج لجنود الاحتلال
الى فتحات الانفاق هذا يطرح سؤالا عن
التحدي الميداني والعسكري الذي يواجهه جيش
الاحتلال في هذه النقطه وكيف يمكن هنا ان
يوازن ما
بين مهاجمه الانفاق
والحذر من ان يقع في
المصيده حسن هو ليس لديه خيار اخر عاده في
هكذا حرب سريعه متسارعه تتغير فيها البيئه
الميدانيه بين ثانيه واخرى حيث لا يوجد
جبهات الجندي الاسرائيلي يتعلم كلما تقدم
كما يقال لرنين بروسس هو يتقدم
كلما يتعلم ياخذ الدروس كلما تقدم هو غير
قادر على التاقلم مع التحولات وذلك بعكس
المقاومه التي لديها الساحه التي تسيطر
عليها وهي تاخذ الدروس بسرعه وتدخلها في
منظومه القتال اسرائيل اليوم تقاتل ثلاث
حروب حسن حرب المدن حرب الانفاق وحرب
البحث عن الرهائن والاسرى حرب البحث عن
الرهائن والاسرى كما كما تقول اي دانيل
هجار يتحدث عن ان هناك عمليات لاستعاده
المحتجزين عمليات
اي تم نشرها او لم يتم نشرها وعمليات ايضا
يقول اوقفنا ماذا فهمت من هذه
العبارات اليوم مشكله الجيش الاسرائيلي او
جيش الاحتلال هو الاستعلام التكت والدقيق
وال والتناقض الحاصل بين السعي لتحرير
الرهائن والاسرى بالقوه العسكريه وبدا
الفشل لعده مرات حيث قتل بعض هؤلاء
الرهائن وعدم القدره على تحريرهم ولا يريد
التفاوض في نفس الوقت
من هنا هناك استراتيجيان متناقضتان
المقاومه تقول الانسحاب وقف النار
والتفاوض وحتى تبييض السجون كما جاء في في
بعض الاحيان بينما يقول الاسرائيلي لا انا
اريد بالقوه العسكريه حتى الان هذا الفشل
يعني القياده السياسيه تضع اهداف القياده
العسكريه غير قادره على تحقيقها حتى هناك
ما يسمى بالعمى الاستخباراتي
والاستخباراتي